Michael Blumenthal, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm great. How are you, Michael?
Thank you so much for having me
on your wonderful show.
I am fantastic.
But you actually go by Michael
in the US right now, Michael?
Very true.
Michael in Israel, Michael in the US.
But I just moved here.
Everyone thought I would go by Michelle.
I just didn't feel like a Michelle.
Michael is a good conversation starter
and it's memorable.
Which is always good for business.
I love it. I love it.
Memorable. Always good for business.
Okay. So, we have to start
with this fun fact
which we've already shared
with our audience.
But folk dancing Hora,
most people watching this
are not going to know what Hora is,
even if they're from Israel.
So, we have to spend a few minutes
talking about folk dancing.
What is this
and why have you been doing this
for 14 years, professionally?
Professionally.
Everyone thinks the Israeli folk dancing
as just the bigger group of people
dancing in a circle, right?
So, that's not what it is, it's actually
a very professional thing to do.
With the company,
we performed all over the world.
So, when I was 15, we went to Brazil
for a whole month.
And we performed
in Paris, Berlin, Russia, even.
So, and it's a great thing to do.
It's really built my character,
I have to say.
So, give me a little bit of context
into what it actually is, tangibly.
So, it's basically any type of dancing,
if it's played to an Israeli song.
And that's pretty much what it is.
It started when the first settlers
came into Israel.
They built it in a Jewish country.
And they they took some
of the traditional dancing
that they brought from their own country,
like Russia and Poland.
And they implemented it
into a new type of Israeli folk dancing.
And it's really evolved over the years.
There's lots of different groups
in Israel right now.
And it's no longer constrained
to just the traditional thing.
It's now very modern dancing.
And that's why I'm saying
it's pretty much anything
that is played over an Israeli song
in the background.
So, when you're saying professionally,
like, what does that actually mean
to do this professionally?
It means that you have a choreographer
that built the dance.
And you have that group of people
that train a lot.
We train about twice
or three times a week
for two hours evey time.
We do ballet training and modern training.
And it's mainly in groups of two.
So, a man and a woman dancing together
through the same choreography.
With the whole costumes.
The whole shebang.
This is definitely something different
than what I imagined.
I'm thinking back to the 60s and 70s
videos of people
dancing together in large circles.
But I definitely have
to go check this out.
And this is actually a pretty nice segway
to something that
we chatted about earlier,
which is this whole notion
of the integration of performing arts
with business and with technology.
And you're running a startup, Hyro AI.
And we'll get to talk about
the NLP side of things.
But first, I want to talk about
this whole notion of performing arts
with business and startups.
Absolutely. I think that performing
takes a big role
in what I do professionally.
I think I associated the performance
with the professionalism
in the Israeli army.
That was the first time it occurred to me.
So, I was very fortunate to be in 8200,
like at many Israelis in the Tech World.
The Intelligence Corp technological unit.
And I was working on a project,
the cyber security project.
And that was very successful.
I don't know how to say it in English,
but in Hebrew we say, we scored it.
How do you translate it to English?
I think we're going to have to keep it
with scored it.
Okay, great.
So, we scored it.
And then all the leaders
of the Israeli army and defense came in.
We had to present the project to them.
And that's the first time
where I was standing
in front of the chief of staff,
the Israeli army chief of staff.
And I felt like I'm taking everything
I learned from performing and dancing
to this world.
And it's really about
engaging your audience
and making them
pretty much adore you
and relate to what you're saying
and what you're doing.
And making sure
your messaging is accurate.
And I think it relates perfectly
to that world.
And then later on, it's in conferences.
The presenting at the booth.
It's even in company meetings,
and sales demos, obviously.
It's in every everything you do.
And you can see that
this is the stage I have right now
for my Zoom meeting.
I have to say that
I can not resonate more.
And we've recorded
almost 200 episodes of this show.
And I'm so happy
that we're talking about this.
This is something
that I have been reflecting lately.
But actually, by the time this comes up,
hopefully a book that I've been writing
will come out.
And a significant part of it
will have been about my experience
with my father taking me on stage
for a tech conference at 13 years old,
not knowing anything but learning slowly
the importance of being able
to deliver messages
in a coherent and concise way.
That's also engaging and then reflecting
on how important it is
when you're leading teams.
And I'm sure that
not only in public speaking,
but also when you're leading your team
with a startup,
and the way you're communicating
and engaging your employees
and the people that are running
this adventure with you.
It's just as crucial.
Give me some insight into
what the specific things
that you've learned over the years
about expressing your opinions
and delivering messages
in not an entertaining way,
but an engaging way that makes people
want to listen to you
and like you said, adore you.
I think the secret is in preparing.
I always say that my superpower
is that I'm always prepared.
And I have to say
I was a bit nervous about this one
because there is no way to prepare.
Sorry, because
I didn't prepare you at all.
This is meant to be spontaneous.
But I already adore you
and I'm very very engaged.
So, you're doing a good job
with the performing arts already.
Stop it. No, I'm kidding.
So, I think preparing is the key here.
Making sure you know exactly
what you want to say,
how you want to say it.
Storytelling is also
very key in performance.
That you know
who you're talking to in advance.
I always like to prepare
like where the person is from,
what he cares about.
A good tip for sales
is to check their LinkedIn account
and see what they posted about.
So, what do they care about,
what are they passionate about,
and building a genuine conversation
around that.
Right. So, a lot of people say
that when you go on stage,
you want to start with the joke.
That always it loosens the audience.
But it sounds like what you're saying
when you're in sales
or when you're talking to somebody
in business is knowing something
that they're curious about.
And bringing that up
is just as important as jokes.
So, I'd love to talk a little bit
about now Hyro,
and what you're doing there.
And I'll bring back performing arts
for this conversation
just because I'm so excited
to talk about it finally.
But talk to me a little bit
about the startup that you're running now.
Absolutely.
So, I'm the chief operating officer at Hyro.
We're an innovative startup.
We're backed by top VCs.
I'm here in the Bay Area,
I'm [--] by the way
In New York and in Tel Aviv.
So, all around.
And we're doing the next generation
of virtual assistance.
So, chatbots for website.
Voice assistance for call centers.
And we have this cutting edge approach
for natural language processing
or how are we able to understand
what the user is saying or asking.
So, virtual assistants,
but conversational AI.
Paint me the ecosystem.
It's getting to be pretty popular.
Almost any website that I go on
that is trying to sell me something,
it does so very successful
because I love engaging
with the virtual bots.
And the famous Turing test
of do you know that you're speaking
to a machine or a person.
It's becoming more and more relevant.
Talk to me about this ecosystem.
And then I'd love to talk more
about actually, the company.
Okay. Absolutely. So, conversational AI
is the set of technologies
that enables humans
to interact with technology, right?
So, things like Alexa, Google home,
Siri, all those great stuff,
and that includes chatbot.
So, if we focus on chatbot,
if you think about the chatbot experiences
that you had, it has two main categories.
So, you have the Dumb Bots,
those are the bots
that everything is pre-configured there.
So, it's all buttons and if and else.
And you have to think in advance
of all the possible questions
users can ask, and provide
all the possible answers in advance.
That's the world of Dumb Chatbots,
that's the most common ones.
Then if you do have an open text field,
which means that you allow users
to say whatever they want,
pretty much it means
that you have natural language
processing and understanding, right?
You have to be able
to break down the sentence,
understand what the user is asking about.
And that's where
natural language processing kicks in.
And then for that world,
we have that traditional approach.
It's fine to call it traditional
because it's a relatively new field anyway.
But that's what most solutions use.
They're all built on intents.
So, for example, when you say,
"Alexa, what's the weather like today?"
That's a weather query intent, right?
And a similar intent would be asking,
"How hot is it going to be today?"
or, "What's the temperature like
going to be today?"
and, "Should I wear a sweater today?"
It's all the same intent, right?
So, in order for the AI to identify
or recognize that intent,
you have to provide something
that's called training data.
So, you have to provide
all the similar phrasing
that I just mentioned,
in order for the AI
to understand this intent
and recognize it.
And it's a very long process.
It takes a lot of manual work.
It's called tagging similar conversations.
It's very expensive and it's limited
to the intent security support, right?
Not very scalable.
So, what we do at Hyro,
we have this whole new approach
for conversational Ai,
which I'm super excited about.
Instead of moduling intent,
we module the language itself.
So, we use computational linguistics
and we learn
all the different language roles.
Like how to identify
the verb in a sentence.
Or how to identify the nouns
in the sentence.
Which means that we understand
in real time
what the user is asking.
And so, we're able to get
a very high quality
of conversation super fast.
It sounds to me like what you're doing
is literally, it's also almost like
third and fourth grade grammar classes.
When kids have to learn,
they're not just learning the intent,
they're learning about
how are sentences formed.
Because when you read a sentence,
only by knowing
the formation of the sentence,
sometimes you can really understand
what the person means.
Sometimes when you just add
a comma somewhere,
you're changing the whole intent
of the sentence.
The famous example I would say
from Hamilton I believe, with Angelica.
Where there's a whole song
about there was a misplaced comma
and it changes the whole meaning
of the sentence, right?
Yes, and Peggy. Don't forget Peggy.
The most important, of course.
I want also I want to talk about
scalable processes.
And one thing that you mentioned earlier
is this idea of running scalable processes
and Scrum Master Agile.
So, you're the chief operating officer.
First of all, give me two sentence brief,
what is the chief operating officer
in your eyes?
So, it varies tremendously
between different organizations.
For us specifically,
I'm overseeing all the commercial aspects
of the company.
So, sales, business development,
partnerships, all of those.
Product market fit and so on.
It can mean different things
for different organizations.
Sometimes it means managing legal
and HR and things like that.
That's what I'm doing for Hyro.
What is the second person question?
Well, specifically, being a scrum master
and running Agile and JIRA,
you've done this in several organizations.
It's something that it sounds like
you're at least
a little bit passionate about.
And I'd love to learn a little bit more
about running scalable processes.
I'm super passionate
about building scalable processes.
I'm a JIRA geek, I would say.
I have actually been called
the JIRA queen
in every organization that I went to.
Because I like to roll up my sleeves
and actually configure JIRA. Configure.
I even wrote a paper for the university
about the Agile development lifecycle.
And I'll tell you why.
I think that once you sit down
to configure a workflow,
it really enforces you to think
about the process
and enforce different steps
in the process.
For example, when you have to define
all the status you have in the workflow,
so now it makes you think.
Does every task
need to go through testing, for example.
If you decide yes,
then you build a status called testing
and that's it.
From now until forever, every test
will have to go through testing.
And that's an amazing way
to enforce processes
across in the organization
in a very scalable way
with very little effort.
Right. Right.
A selfish question.
because I've been in this heated debate
for many years
since my time in the 8200 unit.
Task story points.
For whoever doesn't know,
Oh, I see that
we're going to enter a debate here.
The notion is, for anybody
who doesn't understand JIRA
or Scrum in general, the idea here is that
you are assigning tasks.
And while in day to day we ask each other
how long is the task going to take you,
in JIRA you assign story points to a task
based on complexity.
Now some choose to continue
working through time.
Others choose to work through complexity.
They have their pros and cons.
But MIchael, I'd love for you
to explain to me a little bit about
the pros and cons of each.
Because in every organization
that I've been a part of,
I've seen the good, the bad
and the ugly of both approaches.
And it just seems like there still
is no convergence on one perfect approach.
That's an amazing question.
I personally have a love hate relationship
with story points.
Because on the one hand,
it's psychologically for people,
it's much easier to give story points
instead of saying
it's going to take me four hours.
So, usually you define
what is the story point
for the people
who are not familiar with this,
you just say what's the time unit
that each story point is equal to.
So, when you're giving story point,
when you're giving your estimation
in story point,
you are really giving
your time estimation.
But people, they're having
a much easier time saying it
in story points instead of hours.
So, I do like that aspect
of making it easier for people
to adapt this approach.
Because one of the most difficult things
of moving into
an Agile development lifecycle
is the adaption.
So, engineers tend to hate that.
So, this is the one thing
that can make it easier.
And I do have to say it,
that I personally don't like it,
because why not just say how much time
it's going to take you.
But because I'm very practical,
but I do like it
because JIRA has a built-in tool
to measure velocity through it.
So, if you do use story points,
you can very easily measure
how many tasks you can do
in a sprint.
Sprint is the interval of a week
or two or three
that the team is working in.
If you're doing scrum,
we can go into a Canva also
if you want.
But I don't know how deep you want to go
into the world of Agile.
It's love hate relationship,
but definitely I recommend estimations
and choosing one path and going with it.
Wonderful. So, consistency, at the end
that's the main key, right?
So, there's pros and cons of each,
but with consistency is the key.
And so, when you're entering
these organizations,
what tangibly do you do with JIRA?
Why are you considered the JIRA queen
of these organizations?
Because I enforce the entire organization
to move to JIRA.
And then when they don't do it,
I do it myself and I configure it myself.
So, on the first company I've been with
after the Army, they're called MCE,
Mobile Care Experts.
They're selling into the telecom space.
So, we got to a place where
we were 70 people in the R&D,
or 70 developers.
And we were managing everything.
Every team
was managing their tasks differently
and we implemented the waterfall.
Waterfall is a very old methodology.
Where like a waterfall,
you have different steps in the process.
So, for example, you have design
and then design review,
and then development,
and then testing and then another review.
And it's usually a very long process.
It's a very good way
to manage things at scale
because it's very determined.
But it means that you have
a very long development lifecycle.
Because if you have all these steps
in the process,
the process takes a long time.
So, it's usually like a release cycle
of even six months
to release a new version.
So, we took the 70 people R&D
and we move them from waterfall,
to Scrum, to two-week Sprints.
We started with two weeks.
We ended up after six months,
moving to one week sprint.
Which is amazing in my eyes.
Really.
And I did it back then
as I was the VP of Project Management.
That was part of my role to do that.
Internal processes as well as
the external customer facing processes,
that was my main responsibility.
So we did it very organized.
We took an external company
that helped us educate people
on what is Scrum
and how does a Sprint work
and all the key terms,
which taught me a lot.
And then I was able to do the same
for the other two companies
I've been with.
Wonderful. Wonderful.
That's just incredible.
The difference, at what point
of a startup's life cycle
is it really relevant, do you think,
to start adapting this methodology?
And not just Agile.
Because obviously, I think
the earlier the startup,
the more crucial it is to be agile
and be open to pivoting
and for quick feedback.
But in terms of the tangibly
of operating it
through a software like JIRA or any other,
is it from day one?
Is it from employee number 30?
Is there some rule of thumb
that you're starting to understand
as you were going through
these different organizations?
Absolutely.
As soon as something falls
between the cracks.
As soon as what you currently
have in place is not good enough,
and if tasks are not being done on time,
or if someone has to keep
following up with everyone
to make sure they're being done,
that's when you need to scale it.
That's when you need to scale it. Okay.
So, Michael, 20 minutes are almost over.
But I want to go back a little bit
to performing arts.
Just as a segway into who you are
and what you're passionate about.
You've taken on a variety of roles.
You were talking about performing arts,
to Scrum methodology, to processes,
to conversational AI.
What are you really passionate about?
How do you choose what you spend
your valuable hours of the day doing?
I think I would define it
as I'm passionate about technology.
So, startups that are working
on cutting edge technology
and also, making customers happy.
So, if its the technology that involves
a lot of work closely with customers.
I like to work
with big organizations or enterprises
and build a genuine relationship
that are for the long term,
not just a very short project.
So, continuous work
and showing value over time.
That's what I'm really passionate about.
And scaling internal processes.
I love it. Okay. And before we leave,
I need three words that you would choose
to describe yourself,
or that your co-founders
would choose to describe you.
Okay, great. So, I watch a bunch
of your episodes,
so, I was ready with this question.
I have to say the exercise of deciding
on three words is awesome
and I recommend it to everyone.
So, the first word is problematic
because it's in Hebrew.
Because I couldn't find
a good parallel in English.
So, I'll explain what it means.
It's a bulldozer, okay.
That's what it is in Hebrew.
In English it means,
the literal meaning is a truck
that breaks stones.
And it's a word that's commonly used
to describe people who make things happen.
So, that's my first word.
And then the second and third
is obsessive and passionate.
Bulldozer, obsessive and passionate.
I have to say, that bulldozer
might be my favorite word
out of almost 200 episodes,
I guess that's 600 words.
It's just wonderful.
Michael, this was wonderful.
This was insightful.
Thank you for the time.
I know how busy you are.
And mazel tov on your birthday,
which is just recently right?
And mazel tov in your book.
Thank you. Thank you.
Hopefully by the time this airs,
it'll be out.
We're doing the final touches.
At least now I know how hard it is.
But this was just
a wonderful conversation.
So, toda raba.
Thank you. This is super fun.